[Música]
a brigada é todos os dias eu eu me
questiono muito é o que fazem as pessoas
o que diferencia as pessoas vencedoras
das demais
em outras palavras qual é o segredo da
vitória aquela virada de chave e comecei
a pesquisar e entender a onde estava
esse segredo a e estudei muito as ações
dessas pessoas
então peguei as pessoas mais
inspiradoras as pessoas que a fazem mais
sentido que eu queria me espelhar e fui
ver o que essas pessoas fazem então
gosto delas começou estudando as ações
dessas pessoas a começar vendendo por
grande maioria dessas pessoas a terem
uma base familiar
a grande maioria dessas pessoas acordam
cedo a grande maioria dessas pessoas têm
hábitos saudáveis
a grande maioria dessas pessoas
trabalham muito a estudam em boas
escolas não têm uma tem uma boa formação
aí fazem mba em harvard e essa resposta
essas respostas não estávamos fazendo
porque eu pensei pô m em raiva de tudo
bem é maravilhoso mas junto com aquele
com aquela pessoa tem 12 500 o que fez
aquela ser mais vencedora que as outras
bom a família acho que bastante gente
tem acordar cedo muita gente acorda boa
formação na clássica da faculdade na
escola do m e também tem outras 500
pessoas
então essas respostas de que essas
pessoas fazem comum quais são as ações
dessas pessoas é não me deixaram
satisfeitos
então eu acho que o que mais me deixou
satisfeito
após momentos de reflexões e e e estudos
foram comuns como essas pessoas reagiram
às suas dificuldades aos seus momentos
as suas viradas de chave
então pra mim
ficou claro que o grande o grande barato
grande diferencial está nas reações e
não nas ações
então eu comparo as ações como a
pavimentação do caminho e as reações
como cruzar a linha de chegada uma coisa
não necessariamente está relacionada com
a outra porque para cruzar a linha de
chegada pode ter uma estrada super
complementada duplicada sinalizada e
iluminada mas pode ser um membro cada
pode ser uma a cheia de curvas então a
claro que uma estrada bem pavimentada
vai te levar a linha de chegada de uma
forma mais suave e melhor mas isso aí
não não impede a pessoas que tiveram
muitas dificuldades histórias de
superação de cruzarem a linha de chegada
então trouxe para cá essa reflexão de
ações e reações eu começo a falar um
pouquinho o pai da minha história do meu
caminho das minhas ações
várias delas eu tomei por conta própria
várias outras são a família vai tendo
sindo amigos ea sua cada um vai
construir nossa história então a minha
história as minhas ações foram ações
comuns na china uma ótima família no
interior de minas gerais
estudei um conjunto com vários amigos
mudei para belo horizonte para estudar
fazer faculdade a conseguir um bom
emprego é fiz estágio depois gostava
muito de trabalhar e não conseguiu
emprego a trabalhei bastante nesse
emprego as coisas comuns obtendo
resultados comuns e e tinha sonhos
a audaciosa então o meu grande sonho as
de carreira sempre foi um grande
executivo de uma grande empresa e eu
estava percorrendo muito bem isso a
trabalhando numa grande companhia de
shopping center
foi onde eu acho que encontrei bastante
esse dna de varejo acho que isso
realmente a mim pouco
muito me me deu muita expectativa e
tesão para trabalhar
aí o meu grande sonho era ser um grande
executivo dessa a dessa corporação
e aí veio um grande baque a que mudou
tudo toda a minha vida à foi por volta
de 2014 quando o brasil vive uma grande
crise a essa crise
eu comparo ela como ações externas
então não dependeu de minhas a crise
existir ou não e essa crise foi ruim pra
mim foi ruim para todos os outros também
né e foi um momento que eu mais descolei
de todo o esse ambiente comum que eu
sempre vivi foi na hora que eu reagir a
esta crise
então eu percebi que a grande virada de
chave foi a minha reação a este momento
há muito adverso que foi eu abandonar o
meu sonho abandonar o emprego abandonar
a minha carreira para me tornar um
empreendedor coisa que eu nunca tinha
sonhado nunca tinha pensado não não era
o que eu queria para mim e acabei
mudando a rota recalculando a rota aí
assumir riscos
então nesse momento de crise
a minha reação não foi aceitar a crise
a minha reação foi a enfrentar a crise
mudar a rota a ser agressivo e pra cima
então acho que isso me descolou das
pessoas que ficaram desempregadas
ficaram tristes em casa empresas que
fecharam e aceitaram a derrota e pessoas
que simplesmente desanimaram na
esperando bons ventos ir então essa foi
a primeira diz colada à do do resto e aí
eu como um novo empresário um novo
empreendedor com idéias maravilhosas
há também várias decisões erradas eu fui
muito amador nesse primeiro momento eu
tinha uma empresa mas não sabia como
gerir
acho também que isso faz parte da nossa
formação em geral nem a gente é muito
pouco preparado pra encarar o mercado a
gente é muito pouco preparado para se
empreender
dor a gente é muito mal preparado pra
decisões financeiras há conhecimento de
como investir de como a nossa educação
no geral é muito falha nesse aspecto
então eu como todas as outras pessoas
errei muito mais do que eu acertei e aí
o que eu quero dizer com isso é que as
minhas ações são iguais às de todo mundo
às vezes ações têm sete acertos as
nações têm erros e isso não tem problema
todo mundo tem um buraquinho a na
estrada só que isso não o impede de você
a chegar onde chegou o seu grande
objetivo porque quando também várias
ações erradas que qualquer chama aqui
debaixo desse gene a
o que a maioria dessas pessoas das
outras pessoas que também tomaram
decisões erradas fariam como elas
reagiam ou reagem quando a empresa
começa a ir mal quando a empresa não tem
mais caixa quando a empresa tá beira da
falência você não tem mais clientes você
não tem mais produto o que a maioria das
pessoas fazem como você reage a esse um
sucesso porque o sucesso todo mundo tem
né
então a minha reação à beira do fracasso
foi mais uma vez quando eu escolhi lei
de todos os outros que ficaram pelo
caminho
eu renovei eu renovei a então na hora
que estava tudo ruim em tudo mal à beira
da derrota
a minha reação foi vamos mudar a rota de
novo vamos renovar vamos fazer diferente
vamos criar um novo vão entender o que
está acontecendo e vamos mais uma vez
pra frente não vão cair no buraco passou
back ou segue em frente
o que a maioria das pessoas furou o pneu
pararia o carro né
então essa reação mais uma vez deixou
90% para trás segue os 10 por cento para
frente e aí
também a gente não pode dar muita chance
ao azar
então eu tinha uma empresa e 90 e
transformei ela no banco de franquias e
agora é preciso fazer diferente não
quero cometer as mesmas mesmos erros
para trás não vou fazer merda dos filhos
de novo então me tornei uma pessoa mais
organizada
me tornei uma pessoa a mais planejada
me tornei uma pessoa aço que supera os
próprios dos meus próprios desafios
então eu falei agora tenho que acertar
mais do que errar ou pelo menos uma
coisa nova não podemos cometer os mesmos
erros pra trás
então nesse momento voltando pra nossa a
comparação aqui as decisões super humano
é super comuns
claro que acertando mais o terreno é
muito mais fácil então a com
planejamento com akon preparação a as
oportunidades começaram a aparecer
e aí eu tenho um exemplo que também mais
uma vez mudou a minha vida foi a
possibilidade de fazer um pit de fazer
uma apresentação anusha que tem o brasil
já que tem o brasil
a gente fica de frente com cinco dos
maiores empreendedores do brasil aí você
tem que fazer essa venda ali naquele
minuto naquela hora a para tentar vender
o seu negócio para tentar trazê los como
sócios para trazê los como investidores
e aquilo podia mudar a minha história
então eu me preparei muito para aquilo
eu ralei muito porque eu queria dar o
meu máximo lá então eu volto pro nosso
comparativos digo eu tomei muitas ações
certas que foi ela que foi a própria
preparação eu assisti todos os episódios
de todas as temporadas de todos os
países desse programa então eu virava
madrugada com madrugadas madrugadas com
legendas e legenda dormir no meio
acordava eu queria muito entender o que
estava como chegar àquele resultado
final e pavimento tem muito bem
pavimentado meu caminho
então cheguei sem nenhum arranhão na
frente mas o grande
lance desse programa e que não é
diferente de estar aqui hoje é o que eu
faria na hora da pressão
eu estava preparado isso ajuda mas o
programa é pancadaria o cara que bate de
acha sua fraqueza vai jogar no chão e e
esse programa tem 30 40 50
empreendedores que foram à a maioria
dessas pessoas ficaram nervosas
a maioria dessas pessoas e dá branco a
maioria dessas pessoas e esquecer e mais
uma vez a minha reação e descolou de
todos os outros 90% eu reagi muito bem
eu fui muito pra frente eu fui muito pro
ataque eu estava preparado e essa
confiança me deu muito poder para
enfrentar então meu instinto e e acho
que é muito legal ponto a isso a reação
a mágica da reação é que ela é a
genialidade dela é que é os instintos
animalescos que a gente tem então nem
sempre a gente tem controle sobre isso
tem hora que gagueja já tenha tido
querer voltar a estudar branco e eu não
queria estar a reagir daquela forma
então naquele momento que eu reagi super
positivo veio a conquista ea e essa
conquista
essa conquista mudou minha vida então a
gente bateu o recorde do programa que
era trazer quatro choques de uma só vez
então trouxemos essas pessoas para serem
investidores e sócios do banco do nosso
negócio e isso me rendeu mais frutos de
mais oportunidades a isso abriu as
portas pra mim e fui selecionado pela
forbes a alertar e como um dos jovens
mais brilhantes por esse feito inédito
então as portas foram se abrindo porque
eu passei naquela linha de chegada e que
eu me preparei muito para ela mas que
não sabia como eu ia reagir naquele dia
como também estar aqui hoje
no momento extremamente especial para
minha vida é uma adrenalina muito grande
a gente tem que saber como vai acontecer
e isso aconteceu na hora então é mais
uma vez disso também abriu portas para
mim a volta aqui tá bom o relacionamento
networking que o que a gente fez
além disso foi maravilhoso a faço aqui
uma homenagem ao robson chiba que virou
um amigo um parceiro a depois do
programa então a isso tudo também é
aproveitar as oportunidades e as portas
se abriram
depois dessa linha de chegada e aí eu
entro num outro ponto agora é que eu
gosto muito que é falar do futuro falar
da inovação e da tecnologia isso tudo
vem a de uma forma muito rápida essas
mudanças estão acontecendo muito rápido
então mais uma vez as ações
todo mundo vai acompanhar essa mudança
agora reage a essa mudança reagir a
esses novos tempos que são muito mais
rápidos também não é pra qualquer um e
eu sinto um grande exemplo que é o nosso
mercado no nosso meio a de fast food de
varejo que são aqueles totens de
autoatendimento os tótens são
fantásticos há são totalmente dos
respectivos porque pela primeira vez
você começou a conversar com uma máquina
você faz o seu pedido propor para uma
máquina e não mais para um ser humano
então isso muda totalmente a nossa
história
só que se você enxergar hoje o totem com
uma grande tecnologia você perdeu
totalmente a o sentido da coisa o que
está por trás é muito mais importante
que essa interação com a máquina então a
hoje se você quer acompanhar a
tecnologia e você vai tomar essas
atitudes de agora vou botar totem na
minha loja
ontem já era hoje o que o totem trouxe
para nós foi a possibilidade da gente
tem um super aplicativos um beijo na
máquina
agora você já tá acostumado a conversar
com o robô seja faça o seu pedido pela
mão pelo aplicativo pede é do lado o
escritório já cheguei só pega o então as
coisas estão lá na frente e às vezes a
gente fica ainda tentado reagir ao
passado e eu dou mais um exemplo é o
bitcoin bitcoin foi uma decepção
maravilhosa
pela primeira vez as pessoas entenderam
o que é uma crypton moeda o que é
a o dinheiro universal isso foi
maravilhoso
só que quem está focado ainda no verde
com quem acha que a inovação é o bitcoin
já passou
a inovação e tudo que o bitcoin trouxe é
muito maior que há por trás disso é o
blog em que a forma que a inteligência
que a segurança da informação que isso
sim vai ficar próxima de kovancilar vai
subir ou descer e isso pouco interessa o
que interessa é o que mudou
lá pra frente a mesma coisa os bancos os
bancos digitais
eu vou contar uma história rapidinha
esses dias eu fui montar a minha fazer
uma conta digital em 3d tem nome e cpf
ou não não tira foto da entidade tinha
uma self fantástica experiência
fantástica não tinha não tem agência
tudo digital perfeito
e aí quando ficou pronto o o homem conta
na mesma hora ficou pronta a depositar
100 reais aqui ela já recebeu tudo
perfeito eu vi que não tinha crédito nem
cheque especial nem cartão de crédito
você clicar libera a icann não libera aí
e aí me ligam a gerente ou lá mas eu sou
sua gerente total é o que você faz uma
empresa ou quantos funcionários você tem
aí está medindo o tamanho da empresa
pelo número de funcionários
isso também já passado ok mas segurou a
posse e na sua empresa visitar entender
como é que a sua estrutura digital o que
o digital digital onde a inovação disso
só o aplicativo porque essa pessoa vai
lá no escritório mas vê as pessoas
trabalhando vai isso para análise de
crédito isso para análise de continuar
essa relação do banco ou seja isso é um
itaú é um bradesco é um santo também
travestido de banco digital
então ficou claro que essa não é a
inovação não é essa não é este o futuro
e aí e um time perfeito para esse
pressionar o dia de hoje lançar agora a
apple lançou há pouco o cartão de
crédito da apple que nem é peixe é o
cartão de crédito da época o cartão de
crédito da apple não tem
conta não tem é tudo verdade é face aí é
reconhecimento facial é digital
só isso sim o futuro não tem cara não
tem cor já tem as regras pré-definidas
isso vai ficar nessa coisa de época em
que a tecnologia mas a isso vai ficar
agora é só tirar a agência votar um
aplicativo se você ainda está atrás
disso
esquece que já passou do tempo então eu
gosto muito de falar em relação aos
shoppings também não é como a encontrar
esse novo fornecia é esse novo cliente
como a tendência novo cliente hoje a
gente fala muito de experiência né então
eu gosto muito de olhar pro shopping que
que é um mercado que eu gosto muito
varejo a repita o nosso dna
e eu me pergunto por que sabe como o
shopping hoje para trazer essas pessoas
de retenção dessas pessoas dentro de um
shopping
até hoje o shopping estão fazendo
continuação no gelo na praça de eventos
estão fazendo parquinho de pula pula
fora com aquela expectativa de que o
filho vai mãe como para mim acabou até
hoje estou nessa
então como é que você vai reagir de
verdade a inovação a esses novos tempos
a ou nós vamos fazer o lojista ganhar
dinheiro e o lojista conquistar esse
cliente
vamos fazer mais forte mas o gelo pula
pula e por aí vai
a gente foi um prazer estar aqui com
vocês muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]